if you think that much of anything
related to politics will be settled by
tuesday's election
here's some bad news for you nothing
that matters is really over
nothing is over nothing there are at
least three major issues facing the
country
when either president clinton or
president trump gets sworn in next
january
and when i dropped the towel there had
been significant
shrinkage you may not realize it but the
u.s has been out of recession for
seven years but the average rate of
growth since 2009 has been around 2
percent
making this the weakest economic
recovery since 1949.
economic growth is essential to
improving living standards
and it helps to diffuse all sorts of
explosive political issues from trade to
immigration to welfare
but for all of the 21st century economic
growth has been much lower than what
we're used to
neither clinton or trump has put forth a
plan that will actually grow the economy
clinton will jack up taxes and spending
on everything a surefire way to keep the
economy sputtering along
trump will add more than five trillion
dollars to the national debt which will
also dampen growth
we came we saw he died
hillary clinton is a hawks hawk who has
voted for lobbied for or taken credit
for
all of our military interventions in the
21st century
despite such actions or more accurately
because of such actions
the world is a mess at times donald
trump sounds like he would be a relative
dove and at others
he sounds like a crazy man at the very
least like hillary clinton
he said that he would increase military
spending neither of them has articulated
a foreign policy that will help reduce
international terrorism or bring
order and peace to hot spots in the
middle east eastern europe or asia
anytime
soon hey johnny what are you rebelling
against
what do you got trust and confidence in
most american institutions are at or
near historic lows
the media religious organization's labor
business
you name it that's especially true when
it comes to the two major political
parties and government in general
even worse millennials aren't just the
biggest generation
they're the most skeptical who can blame
them or us
the iraq war was sold on bad information
and prosecuted poorly
president obama's claims that his health
care reform would let you keep your
doctor was the lie of the year in 2013
and we've learned that democrats and
republicans don't give a rat's ass about
the government spying on us
wikileaks and others have exposed
hillary clinton as two-faced at best and
donald trump is a serial scam artist and
bully
neither will address the massive and
ongoing evacuation of trust and
confidence in government and politics
if anything they will likely pour gas on
this dumpster fire
this means america is moving rapidly
from a high trust society to a low trust
one and that's really bad news
especially for those of us who want a
government that spends less
and does less why because paradoxically
people in low trust countries turn to
government in
ever higher numbers in a cruel and
unpredictable world they want a
protector
no matter how untrustworthy politicians
and their supporters can act responsibly
and put forth serious plans for reducing
the size scope and spending of
government
gary johnson and bill well did precisely
this the two former governors spoke not
of zero government but of smaller
government that did fewer things
more effectively such characters are few
and far between
but there are enough elected officials
in each party to at least
insist on government performing its
basic functions
such as passing actual budgets each year
until the major parties start governing
in the light of day
and especially stop nominating
candidates who are disliked by
majorities of americans
don't expect much to change except for
things to get even nastier
you